bonjour thierry un gros merci de
répondre à nos questions directes sur
arte france olivier vers ont dit qu'ils
naviguent pas à vue au sujet de la
campagne de vaccination il est
auditionné en ce moment même par les
parlementaires le ministre de la santé
se décharge sur les expertises de la
haute autorité de santé comment est-ce
que vous accueillez ses propos cet après
midi il se veut rassurant vous êtes
rassurés ben nous ce qui nous semble
vraiment important c'est d'utiliser ou
au mieux les doses de vaccins que l'on
en a qui arrivent de petit à petit pour
les centrées sur les personnes qui en
ont le plus besoin les plus de jus plus
de 75 ans donc il faut vraiment mettre
le paquet là dessus on sait bien que
j'ai eu un retard au niveau français et
donc il ya eu la tentation de faire un
peu plus de deux chiffres vers les
populations qui ont besoin d'être
vaccinés
parce qu'ils sont au contact avec la
population comme les soignants les
pompiers les auxiliaires de vie mais
néanmoins pendant ces quelques semaines
où on est très juste en doses
il faut vraiment utiliser le maximum de
doses pour les personnes âgées de plus
de 75 ans qu'elle soit on n'est pas de
quel fâchée elle parce que c'est pour
ces personnes là que le risque de
décéder du coc vide est plus important
vous dites on est juste en dose une
grande partie de nos positions elles
évoquent une pénurie de vaccins olivier
ferrand dément il n'y aurait pas aussi
assez d'aiguilhe également vos pieds de
son terrain coûte du dispositif
logistique
oui clairement on aurait besoin de plus
de doses pour vacciner plus plus de
personnes bon on a une même cafouillage
avec la vaccination antigrippale e
annuels très rapidement on a manqué de
vaccins contre la vie donc là on n'ait
pas davantage surpris d'avoir le même
problème pour un vaccin qui en plus
pause qui problème
de logistique plus importants du fait de
la conjuration pour le chat liseur mais
comment est-ce que vous l'accueillez
vous cette stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement vous êtes satisfait pour le
moment est ce que vous l'a condamné ce
qui est important c'est la stratégie
définie par la haute autorité de santé
stratégies graduée qui commence par les
plus fragiles ceux qui sont en
hébergement contre 8 75 ans qui font
d'hébergement collectif et ensuite dès
qu'on peut les plus de 75 ans a qui
vivent vie chez eux parce que c'est que
qui ont le plus que de risques de
décéder du tuco vite donc c'est vraiment
sur ces populations là qu'il faut
concentrer le plus d'efforts vous êtes
rassurés par les propos d'olivier
verrons aujourd'hui devant les
parlementaires n'ont clairement on
manque de vaccins on sait pas où sont
mes il faudrait faire beaucoup plus de
preuve de souplesse avec des équipes
mobiles qu'ils puissent se déplacer là
où on peut et moi dans la logique de
gros vaccinodromes même s'il y a il ya
la tentation on voit bien en allemagne
que ça pose d'autres d'autres problèmes
et il vaut mieux être le plus souple
possible faire confiance aux territoires
pour envoyer des équipes partout c'est
aussi pour vacciner le maximum de
personnes âgées pendant cette période de
charniers conseil de défense demain
matin point presse de jean castex jeudi
soir à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
pas de confinement et hier matin selon
les mots de gabriella talent pour parle
du coût du gouvernement et je cite un
recond finement n'est pas exclu selon
les mots cette fois hier après midi de
jean castex qui croire
ce qui est terrible c'est l'attitude du
gouvernement par rapport aux
établissements scolaires
on voit bien qu'un certain nombre de
pays ont organisé le massivement les
soucoupes avec une dédicace géré par un
professeur à une demi-classe géré par un
adulte référent qui fait soit études
dirigées groupe de travail bien fait de
monstres etc cela va dépendre des
chiffres ou mais ce qui nous inquiète
vraiment c'est par rapport aux
établissements scolaires
nous nous voyons bien le sort la table
de l'exécutif il y aurait selon certains
médias le fait qu'on ferme les comptines
c'est possible ça selon vous certain
nombre de problèmes de logistique mais
c'est vrai que depuis le départ on a six
sur le fait que vous avez 400 jeunes qui
sont ensemble à manger sur un créneau
horaire limite et le sans masque bien
entendu il donc c'est une vraie
difficulté
encore une fois la points de faiblesse
français c'est par rapport aux
établissements scolaires et on voit
qu'avec l'histoire du variant anglais
qui cibleront prioritairement les plus
jeunes
ça pose de gros problèmes en terme de
transmission qu'il faut vraiment agir
sur les établissements scolaires et là
on est très mauvais en france quand on
voit qu'il ya des pays qui ont installé
des purificateurs d'air dans chaque
classe qui on multiplie les niveaux et
que nous on est incapable de le faire et
on est toujours très en retard la tille
c'est un gros souci vous êtes infirmier
un tir est amoureux on parle beaucoup
des infirmiers pour qu'ils puissent
vacciner sans les médecins idem pour les
pharmaciens aussi votre position par
rapport à ça will et dans l'ensemble du
monde les infirmer
en première ligne pour la vaccination
diacon france où on est beaucoup retard
parce que les médecins ont du mal à
donner leurs vrais classe aux
infirmières
on est six cent mille infirmières en
france donc c'est une armée à laquelle
on reprenant ce qui qui plus est elles
130 mille infirmières libérales qui sont
les dernières professionnel à aller au
quotidien au domicile des personnes
donc il faut vraiment donner le plus de
coudées franches aux professionnels
infirmiers pour aller vacciner partout
c'est possible merci mme tirer amoureux
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
du syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers